le voy a pedir a los tres que cierran
sus ojitos a los tres por unos momentos
y van a imaginar cómo se visualizan
ustedes de acá digamos o un año o cinco
años a ver tú dylan cómo te ha
visualizado
terminando la carrera hoy qué bonito que
estás en cusco cusco y usted señora
jenny como se ha visualizado
[Aplausos]
teniendo un trabajo
un negocio muy
imaginar el futuro intentando olvidar un
pasado doloroso milán y su hermana
graciela perdieron a su padre debido a
complicaciones del cob y 19 hoy sin
ingresos su madre tuvo que hacerse cargo
de la familia ella ha recibido apoyo del
programa de bienestar familiar inabif
que depende del ministerio de la mujer
dos meses recibe aproximadamente 260
dólares estadounidenses
hace dos años y mi esposo
pero con la ayuda que me están dando en
audio de ecológica prácticamente me
ayuda a mí también para sacar adelante a
mis hijos por el momento
es la preocupación del estudio de la
alimentación ya que nos dejó en cero y
esto es una ayuda muy grande para
nosotros
pero más allá de la ayuda económica
inabif también proporciona apoyo
psicológico cónyuges
en cuanto al emocional es mucho más
importante porque se les está ayudando
para que puedan tener estrategias o
algunas herramientas para poder afrontar
estas etapas que están pasando las
familias
en perú aproximadamente 100.000 niños
han perdido al menos a uno de sus padres
durante la pandemia
es la cifra más alta registrada en el
mundo
hoy cerca de 18 mil familias en esta
situación reciben antes de reyna vida
en esta otra familia del distrito de san
juan de lurigancho el padre que murió de
kobe también dejó una familia en total
desesperación
alguien me casa ante todo vuelto las
cosas a recuperar pero perdí a mi esposo
formas que hice lo imposible me endeudé
hice de todo
pero así fue
bueno no llegó un momento que yo no
existía que no iba a poder
pero gracias a dios mis hijos son como
la fuerza que va para salir adelante y
ahora con esta ayuda para mí es muy
importante
y es muy valioso este dibujo
cualquier cosa
[Música]
perú se vio muy afectado por la pandemia
del cob y 19 durante muchos meses los
servicios de reanimación estuvieron
saturados 212 mil muertes y 33 millones
de habitantes el país tiene la tasa de
mortalidad más alta del mundo aunque la
pandemia se está estancando los efectos
se siguen notando
y el inabif planea apoyar a más
huérfanos en todo el país
queremos empezar con 25.000
beneficiarios y terminar de aquí unos
años con 85 mil a 90 mil estamos
haciendo un registro de orfandad algo
que no existía en el perú y es probable
que los números sean mayores a los que
nosotros calculábamos
en los barrios desfavorecidos de lima el
cobre 19 dejó su huella los comedores
sociales permiten a muchas familias
necesitadas alimentarse cada día entre
ellas a los huérfanos y a las viudas
[Música]
más de 3 millones de peruanos cayeron en
la pobreza desde el comienzo de la
pandemia en marzo de 2020 a pesar de las
ayudas estatales cada vez más
disminuidas el futuro de los huérfanos
por el cob y 19 sigue siendo incierto
[Música]
sí